what's happening now
october 1st the day the devil was [ __ ]
in the ass
giving ebola then they gave him to
[ __ ] isis
isis don't kill black people
here we go kick that [ __ ] lee
what wiggle funko pajar what
oh [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what i
never kid what
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] listen to angus young i don't
know how old he was he was just killing
this [ __ ] guitar kick that
[ __ ] lead what
oh
[ __ ] take that monkey out
lick it
flick it
stick it in there lick that
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] is on fire lee syed
welcome welcome to you [ __ ] at
home to the church of what's happening
now guess what we got no guests tonight
we got my girl betty paige calling in
from the [ __ ] bunny ranch to tell us
how she got into it what she does her
specialty all that type of [ __ ] it's
just me and the [ __ ] flying jew
welcome what's happening buddy not much
man what [ __ ] you bangkok sucker what to
the questions i've been everywhere like
i've been on the elliptical been over at
skinny kitchen getting a great meal or
even where else can i go i like that
club chicken sandwich over there oh it's
so good it's just it's grilled chicken
they have a nice cheese they have turkey
bacon to save so you at least feel like
you're still getting bacon i i don't get
the blue cheese dressing i go for
mustard if the but where is that is the
fries
the fries are like baked and it's only
100 calories i don't i don't use the
ketchup because i'm trying to save but
it's like nice and crispy like potato
wedges they're delicious very nice so
it's a nice time and everything is good
oh yeah and it's got a goat cheese
omelet
like heather mcdonald [ __ ] kidding me
a goat [ __ ] cheese i'm are you
kidding me this is what we got to deal
with in that way goat cheese almond you
imagine you're waiting having a bad day
[ __ ] chick comes up to you for a goat
cheese omelet tell me you wouldn't
[ __ ] pull out one of those isis
[ __ ] knives and slice a [ __ ]
jugular i know i would
or i liked it but goat cheese made me
throw up the one time i had oh it's
[ __ ] that's for [ __ ] people i
don't know i ain't go to get go [ __ ]
your mother goat cheese
fight blue cheese [ __ ] goat
cheese or american cheese yeah or swiss
don't tell me cheddar cause so help me
gotta hitch in the head [ __ ]
microphone it's nice it's for [ __ ] it's
like american cheese 2.0 no
no no no no it's a beautiful
[ __ ] day to be alive it's great
to be here just talking [ __ ] you know
when we do the podcast with the guests
it's just a different variation you know
we don't get to say much we do but
uh you know it's about to guess so we i
think it's somebody i don't get to say
much you you always talk you don't say
[ __ ] because you're [ __ ] stoned to
death like that oh my god
now you're talking because i didn't
[ __ ] that's it we're not doing no
more edibles we went deep i don't
believe someone write this date down we
proved our [ __ ] loyalty to so kind
cookies and
the [ __ ] chef the new chef
the the and i gave him a donut i mean so
kind makes donuts those little listen i
gave george one
in new york i gave it to him like when
we checked it
i checked into the hotel maybe about 7
30 quarter day
by nine o'clock he was at the restaurant
he was just looking straight
and he would look at the food need it
and then look up and look and finally
goes listen guys i gotta excuse myself
george was on heroin for [ __ ] 10
years that's how strong [ __ ] soaked i
mean and they don't sponsor us none i'm
just listen at the beginning of the show
we were talking about hit e6
you know if you go to a store they cost
10 bucks they only last one day and
maybe two days the reason why we have
the 86 as a
sponsor it's a great value we're looking
for value here when you go to a chinese
[ __ ] lunch they give you the soup the
[ __ ] fortune cookie
steam rice the egg roll it's a value you
go there you go wow for 699 they even
give you a [ __ ] soda you know
same thing with [ __ ] hitti e-cigs
same thing with everyone we're involved
with yeah no everybody you know the life
is great they always they always they
come around like weed santa claus every
time they're down here with the back i
just finished [ __ ] the peanut brittle
two three days ago but uh it's funny how
uh
i forgot what i was gonna [ __ ] say
talking about george
george and the [ __ ] food for the
[ __ ] money like a place to go to uh
you know this chinese place in chinatown
whatever but what i'm trying to say to
you is that uh for the 12 like i went to
the store here they have a 40 edible now
that's 750 milligrams
right and they're not gonna sell it
because weed is you know for 15 bucks
yeah more than a week so it's 700 and i
told them it's too high level for this
neighborhood they got regular ones for
20. they don't go nowhere they're 180
cal and us milligrams and you know what
the one
[ __ ] little brownie would do more
damage than those 20 ones i put the one
little whole brownie over a [ __ ] uh
uh green hornet oh that's
tough and that's a tough call because
the green on it for 10 bucks is the best
[ __ ] value out there you know like
yeah something like that i don't know
what they charge for goomies or models
but those 250 calorie gummies
they [ __ ] you up oh yeah they [ __ ] you
up too there's a couple things that take
you over there's a couple things at the
store that you got a couple things just
take you there and they they're getting
away with taking you there i want to get
[ __ ] up i want to go over the top
i want to see [ __ ] i want to giggle by
myself
you know i want to scratch my nuts and
you know what the donut wasn't bad the
peanut butter really made it a little
bit better because usually
i'm i don't like weird taste and i just
for whatever reason chocolate and weed
never really does it for me that's why i
prefer gummies uh but
the peanut butter really helped but you
know what on the elliptical yesterday i
didn't have a movie and i think i
figured out why you're giving me the
edibles because i used to get not mad
but i've been trying to die and i keep
[ __ ] up with it with the uh munchies
on these edibles and i think i figured
out why you give them to me why because
i
i i'm sure you've done it a thousand how
many times have you lost and gained the
weight back eight thousand times no no
no just that one time you know and then
when i was a kid
uh one year i wanted to get ready for
basketball and i wanted a tuna diet all
summer
with just one slice of american cheese
and a protein shake and there was the
wrong way of dieting but it worked right
when i was 19. you know yeah but i must
have get lost and gain weight at least
six times at least
and i've been good on this diet but i
feel like what i came to the conclusion
of yesterday on the elliptical was
is that
the edible is showing me that me eating
like that is still in me
and even though it'd be great not to
have the edible i feel like it's
it's forcing me to to fight
you like that
so you always tell me how come you go
home and you don't eat cause i go first
thing i do when i go home is i drink a
coffee
when i have those there's there's tricks
for everything when you talk to a
a brick mason a guy that uh carries
airport luggage the first day you start
you're gonna go jesus christ i almost
didn't come back i was so sore yeah and
then he'll teach he carries a hand cart
he does this he does that and he's like
you don't work you figure out how not to
work that hard yeah i figured out how
not to
let now when i smoke dope i don't get
munchies really when i eat edibles oh
jesus [ __ ] mother of christ
late night especially the more sugar the
edible has yeah that's why i always try
to get low calorie edibles
and low sugar and [ __ ] like that chiba
chew even the chocolate ones is 60
calories that ain't gonna make you throw
your diet off with five grams of sugar
oh no the edible itself
no but if i give you a so kind cookie
yeah that's all [ __ ] sugar and milk
and eggs so you're gonna that sugar is
gonna [ __ ] drive you insane later
later on in the night yeah like a two
you're [ __ ] starving sometimes that's
why i give it to you go home and pass
out yeah if you get up then i get up and
i ate four tangerines oh wow you know
what it's like to eat four [ __ ]
tangerines and by the third one i wasn't
even chewing them i was just sticking
them in my mouth like a [ __ ]
well that's because i didn't that weed
makes everything taste like the most
delicious thing delicious and the
tangerines were sweet but after two
tangerines i don't care how sweet they
are you're like jesus i want a [ __ ]
uh steak sandwich yeah and that's that's
what i have to work on because i
i've gone home and not eaten and i'm
fine it's almost like when you start
eating on an edible it opens it up even
more
so just start cooking and [ __ ] here's
the secret i used to go out and go to
mcdonald's but i was trying to no no
you're better than that now you're at
least better than that but here's the
secret to it is to go home and find
things to eat like you try with those
[ __ ] rice cakes but they're so bad
so that's why i would never eat a rice
cake i'd eat something but one thing i'd
eat is all i'm gonna eat and it'd have
to be really healthy so if i had to cook
something i'd make a tuna sandwich light
on the mayonnaise heavy on the tuna and
maybe use one piece of bread and a
couple crackers
just to keep it low to fill me up i
think four crackers i don't know how
many calories not many depending on what
kind you get that's what i'm saying
i don't even think i can eat anything
there's little tricks i just have to run
into my bedroom and hi i don't need
a cheeseburger deluxe no more and an
order of steak fries
and a cream of turkey soup with a hair
in it stop it
stop it from a diner a jersey diner you
got to have the hair cream of [ __ ]
turkey soup a little strand of hair like
it could be a greek hair or a portrait
do you even take it out or just take it
like that to go to go it's like eating
[ __ ] every once in a while you inhale
the hair what either you stop and pick
it no you just you just
you just swallow that [ __ ]
isis here
if you're eating a monkey and that thing
goes into your throat and it's just
there while you're sucking [ __ ] what do
you do you're not going to stop and
embarrass the girl you're just going to
swallow that hair like a [ __ ]
in-and-out cheeseburger i've never one
get in my throat why not you got to bite
it off you don't take that hair
and they go crazy what are you doing
down there i'm a [ __ ] savage
that's what i'm doing you bite the hair
sure you blow your little haircut with
your teeth
you just bite that [ __ ] hair let them
know they [ __ ] around you'll bite that
[ __ ] real hard too
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore it's still
wednesday night the day the devil was
buried at [ __ ] sea
that's it new york was great i tell you
what i realized about new york that was
really uh and i wanted to talk to the
people because i got a couple i've been
getting great emails lately
and uh
one guy was talking about pain and i was
thinking about what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about who's gonna have to play
in northbrook you know
when i go the club gives me an allowance
like most hotels when you work at comedy
club most comedy clubs have a few hotels
in the area
they do a deal with depending on the
size of the comic that's coming in you
know uh joe rogan gets a complete way
better room than i get you know d.o.u
gets a complete better room than i get
bill berg it's a great room you know
don't get me wrong i get a nice room but
they get sweets with butlers and [ __ ]
you know
uh
you know
me i'm the type of guy i can sleep
anyway i'm not like [ __ ] heather i
can sleep anyway as long as it's [ __ ]
uh you know i i've slept in some wild
places
when i go to north bergen i sleep at the
holiday inn express
the only one with that because i tell
you why there's reasons why because the
other hotels are in fort lee way away
from what my world is
or i could stay in the city which means
i'm going to be in north bergen for a
few days so i'm going to keep going back
and forth that's just an extra ride cab
ride february right i might as well just
stay in norfolk all i'm doing in the
city is those two nights of comedy and
going over there maybe eating dinner
over with anthony over at the something
you know i'm not
in new york so did you see him at the
palms this weekend you know he came to
the show friday night anthony but i did
not i remember seeing his face
but there were so many people god okay
you really can't talk you really there
was so many well you had like a few
hundred people there at night right i'll
tell you what man the new york crowds
are i'm home yeah i'm home in a lot of
comedy clubs when i worked there they're
my second home but this
gotham and this crowd that keeps coming
to the same show
uh renee and another [ __ ]
good-looking kid and a bunch of them
it's uh
we're new york people the people that
are coming and a lot of puerto ricans
the dominicans they feel me they
understand where i'm coming from you
know i heard that asian guy just took a
vacation which one the asian guy who
wouldn't shut the window who got mad no
they blocked them out they [ __ ]
blocked them out and they made everybody
go in i guess the one night they made
had to get off earlier or something just
not to have problems out there you know
they called me the one that
wanted to repeat of what happened so
me i don't give a [ __ ] i like when
people show up the the network shows up
and uh the family shows up and we smoke
dope outside and everything
but this it was still a great crowd
i was at the stand
thursday night that's ari's club that's
why ari does a lot of comedy at the
stand
and [ __ ] lee the food is tremendous
that's what i've heard i had a crab cake
sandwich with arugula on a multi-grain
bread it was [ __ ] delicious
you eat arugula i love it i'm surprised
it's like a lettuce right oh no it is
that is i just thought you would have
been like there's been [ __ ] icebreak
for 74 years now eating arugula
even arugula it was like a spinach i was
saying arugula just because i love crab
cakes it was delicious delicious i think
george had the steak sandwich and he
said it was not bad at all nice comedy
club small
very intimate staff is [ __ ] off the
chain
you know pat mulligan the guy who books
it they they used to do cringe humor
okay
so uh that's where they're from and they
opened up a club so that it was all very
enjoyable but getting back to pain you
know i stay at that hotel because when i
have nothing to do in the afternoon i
force myself to walk around that
neighborhood
the same neighborhood was it in the
neighborhood you grew up in yeah
right by the county right by the york
hotel where the iceman killed the guy in
half we stayed not the hotel you and i
stay there i stay at the one next to it
the smaller holiday inn express then
there's the york hotel behind it which
is the best western or some
thursday i walked to mckinley walked up
the stairs took me [ __ ] 25 minutes
those are the stairs of death i was i
had a limp up the last two levels you
know i was already up there that's why
you were skinny as a kid and then i
walked down the hill and then i walked
the ray canelos and lisa messina's house
how's he doing right now i didn't see
him this was his old house oh old house
okay so i walked over there to the
corner and i saw their old house and
what had happened then i walked back to
one day
then the other day i actually walked to
charles court and walked around the
neighborhood nobody was out in the
street
and uh i never made it to giving that
terrorist i didn't feel like going up my
old block i don't know why something
just
i think that this time the pain hit me i
realized why when i go to new york
sometimes i get a little froggy
i gotta get out of there because i gotta
leave before the pain settles the pain
comes in little spurts it reminds me you
know i was telling you guys monday i
went to the cemetery that's the first
thing i do when i get off the [ __ ]
plane so you went to the cemetery and
you didn't go to given terrace no wow
it's like right next door yeah i went to
the cemetery with uh carlos and i put
flowers and i cleaned the grave off and
there was rocks in the bottom i mean i
pulled the weeds up in my hand you know
it was uh
and while i was doing it i couldn't
believe that uh like i said yeah i have
been going to this funeral parlor for 35
[ __ ] years at the cemetery
but i cleaned off a plot really good and
i put the rocks to look really sharp and
i did that and i saw bobby bender and i
saw carlos and i saw uh
loops the first night great to see him
games metals red chicken collards oh how
what is that like though it's uh
i can't even imagine going to your
parents graves i've been very lucky i
don't have any grandparents left but
they all passed away when i was younger
i can't imagine going there
like i it has gotten easier has it
gotten harder that has to be terrible i
don't know
i don't know because once i go into that
cemetery all those feelings come back
yeah
uh for a minute while i'm standing there
i even my mind takes me away like it
takes me away to
the year after she died and i had all
these things on my mind all this
heartache and this confusion and uh
fear you know i had all these things
and i go through those emotions every
time i stand on that grave
but i leave happy
like i leave very content when i go to
the grave i leave like if uh
i don't know i couldn't imagine there's
a couple times i've gone back and not
gone to the grave and
i felt really shitty for a few months
and then when i've gone back i've made a
point and then one day i just said you
know what
from now on when i go back it's the
first thing i do before there's parties
or talking or chit chat or meeting
people it takes 10 minutes takes 10
minutes i go i buy the [ __ ] thing of
flowers for 35 bucks 40 bucks i go down
i dig a hole i put it in there i kneel i
smoke a joint sometimes i talk to her
you know
and uh that's it that's basically it you
look around that neighborhood and what
it's become and uh
how they put thing you know i uh
i was saying monday when i grew in that
neighborhood i never walked on that side
of the cemetery whenever i walked up and
down that hill before she passed away
before she passed i wouldn't i'm telling
you i wouldn't even [ __ ] walk they're
creepy places man
and now i gotta walk in there and walk
in there like a man you know and walk
out like a [ __ ] man so it's always
been a weird situation but nah man
everything was great you know uh
in fact today i called two of the people
that i saw and i told him i really
missed him it was that type of uh
of a weekend you know
that's awesome it's
that i mean it's
you've always talked about you told me
ever since i've been going home that
each time you go home it's for shorter
and shorter
and it is weird going back but i i've
ever since i've known you you've
probably gone back for four or five
times
and it this is the first time you've
been like you're usually like happy to
get back and this side's pretty cool
that you're and getting to enjoy it now
no i'm enjoying the whole uh the pace of
it at this time i didn't let myself get
bullied into seeing 50 people
i didn't make plans to go eat any big
dinners with anybody i didn't really see
veneri i didn't even talk to an area i
didn't talk to a lot of people and talk
to carmine
didn't talk to a lot of people just
because
i just didn't have the time it's a
business trip it's a business trip it
was raining the one day that took a day
away
i walked in the rain that day from in
new york and then over the shuttle and i
went for a walk to mckinley i just
walked in the [ __ ] rain well you must
have done that a thousand times thousand
times it never rains in california so i
might as well take advantage of it feels
great to [ __ ] feel
raindrops fall on your head and whatnot
but no it was great ah i didn't get i
worked out at the hotel i didn't go to
giulio's jiu jitsu because we missed
times we missed communications um but no
i went to today how'd it go
it was great i went last week to vmac
and did a couple hip escapes and some uh
guard retention and [ __ ] like that
today i went and i thought i was only
gonna be there for 15 minutes and he
made me do the whole [ __ ] class but
he didn't make me spar everything else
he made me do the technique
after the class he made me take my pads
off and show him my knee and he goes you
know what i'm lucky i didn't make you
spar it's still swollen i want you just
to keep coming
do the techniques do the warm-up when
you want to tap out you know go on the
side i didn't tap out that i did the
whole it was great i really enjoyed
going there how's your stamina
horrible yeah today when i was doing hip
escapes there was one point i actually
had to get up and catch my breath and i
started doubting myself maybe i'm gonna
get a heart attack and you know the
whole thing
yeah well he said he lost the weight in
new york i didn't that's amazing he went
to the heart doctor because i was going
to a heart doctor yesterday
and that [ __ ] is a candidate
about weight you know he's anti-weight
so i knew that i didn't want to go in
there real heavy so i wanted that pretty
[ __ ] life for me you know compared to
that he even said something to me
because you're all working on it
but he goes i need you really about 250.
so i gotta go to [ __ ] work you know
but it was uh yeah what that my fitness
what's name my fitness pal it's great it
uh
and the thing is it's not trying to
to go about it a new way even even the
weight watchers which everyone loves and
works great for you is switching it to
points
all this is is it's not even telling you
to do anything it's just saying
log your food if you want to lose weight
this is how many calories you get for
your size
put your food in put your workout in put
your water in and it just tells you at
the end of the day
based on what today was in six weeks or
five weeks you'll be here
if every day was like today
and it's been
you know what people sometimes people
say oh you're not supposed to count
calories you know what man that that's
probably true what about but it works
weight yeah you know listen man this how
many people on this earth
something familiar
at the same time we're so different and
we all have different body types and
different things work for different
[ __ ] people just because i squat 20
squats a day and lose 80 pounds doesn't
mean that's gonna work for you right you
might have something different your
testosterone levels there's so many
variables
you find something that works for you my
whole thing is
accountability
and countability in life and accountable
i really lost weight when i watched when
i did weight watchers because you write
down what you eat and then at the end of
the week i'll look at it and go do i
really need that yeah now i eat a
sandwich there's no chips involved this
shouldn't be chips in your life at all
at all that's just an extra it's like
when you eat fat people like me when i
go to eat and somebody goes i'm taking
you to dinner you want some wine [ __ ] no
i'm saving calories for the good [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i'm saving my
space it's like when you go to a buffet
and you see these [ __ ] gentiles
getting like [ __ ] at the buffet line but
at the end there's lots of tales but
you're eating [ __ ] well i'll get one
later no go [ __ ] bang those
[ __ ] out right now get your
paperwork
get your [ __ ] paperwork you know it's
the same thing you see what you need to
eat and you see what you could live
without yeah and you go why didn't eat
that bag of juices on their [ __ ]
calories first whenever i ate those
[ __ ] little bags of chips i want
three bags yeah of course so why even
[ __ ] around let me just eat the sandwich
let it settle and then we'll see if
we're hungry and then we'll take the
apples or take the peaches or whatever
the [ __ ] you got in your heart in your
heart and your
thing and cut it with that you know yeah
it's really amazing
the act of dieting you call it a diet or
a lifestyle yeah that's all that mixes
together a little walking a little gym
a little eating good a little drinking
water a little bit of sun some great
rest
that's included i went to bed 11 last
night i was walking around 4 30 in the
[ __ ] morning
these are little things i can't you know
i'm saying like i just woke up and just
woke up i went to pee went back to bed
and i cursed myself because i asked you
we want to do a podcast this morning
okay i said we should have woken up in
the [ __ ] podcast this morning
but no it's uh i enjoy this i enjoy this
listen i'm a healthy fat [ __ ] i'm not
gonna lie to you
i may be obese or whatever the [ __ ] you
call that's the [ __ ] regular gentiles
you know what i walk around
i go to the ymca you know i'm tight i'm
a fat [ __ ] but i'm tight yeah you know i
do my thing or at least i try and that
makes me feel a little better and just
like i got a guy across the street from
me you've seen that [ __ ] guy oh that
guy was me that guy would have been me
if i didn't stop his whole body is dead
like his whole
his whole uh demeanor that food that
he's eaten all those bags of junk food
are killing who he is
if she's not happy you can't see that
you know
healthy food makes you feel happy when
you eat healthy you feel a lot better
about yourself yeah [ __ ] yeah when you
look at a [ __ ] thing a mexican
coca-cola
and you go you know what i could live
without that boy when you get in that
car and drive do you feel good about
yourself oh yeah it's like anything else
like turning down a drink is it turning
on a line of coke you came through for
yourself you coming through for yourself
as well you put the air on you coming
through for yourself is one of the
biggest things you could do as a human
being
when i leave that [ __ ] jiu jitsu
class when i get in my car i say a
prayer for making it
i ain't gonna lie to you i say a little
prayer and i let a candle for making it
for not dying hey at least you went to a
class and i went to the class
i went to the class you know it's
amazing how you have to look at this
[ __ ]
so i always uh i don't reward myself
that's where you go wrong
people don't fall fuckingly next thing
you know you own the building we'll open
up a jews express in here where a guy
could get a black suit in a hurry but
you always have to try that'd be a
[ __ ] idea like a black student a
yamaga and a hurry come see lee
a little [ __ ] disguise though
whatever you call it but no that's uh
it's really it's really
i think my best uh accomplishments or i
do something for myself how i feel
like when i do something i didn't want
to do yes i had to go to a doctor on
century city at 10 15.
it's either 405 the 101
or laurel king and you know when i left
early and i made it on time yeah and
it's always the things i don't want to
do once i do them oh my god do i feel
good about myself and that's what people
should be thinking that's what's going
out of your comfort zone oh yeah same
[ __ ] thing well for months before i
started working out you would call me
every day and and get on me about
walking
and i'm a lazy person
when it doesn't when when it comes to
work i like working but when it comes to
exercise i just it has never been for me
so i would fight it i would do a small
one i wouldn't really do it
but it's crazy how
in the few months that i've been working
out it's gone to the point now where
i feel guilty about not going and i feel
great when i do go even it's like today
i had a busy day i did two podcasts
earlier and i and i had to go do some
other stuff at home so i only did half
an hour on the elliptical day but
i still got 400 calories in i got up a
little bit of a sweat and it's better
than that you got your blood going you
got a little bit straight you got some
muscles going you know what i'm saying
if you do a little stretching your liver
got clean you detox your liver you detox
your kidneys you know there's so many
[ __ ] things
that it does and i was very fortunate
because as a young kid my work ethic for
basketball was all lifting weights so i
got used to it and it's something that
nobody wants to do lee
no listen lee it's like you know
nobody wants to do this [ __ ]
unless you know you you but once you go
and you get into a system and you
realize that it makes you feel so good
about yourself and some people said oh
my god i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about i just know that i just
did something good for myself i used to
do a lot of bad things for myself
you know now i do something good for
myself it's amazing i went from doing 20
bad things a day and one good thing
to 20 good things a day and one bad
thing
you know it's amazing how you change
your life around how you go for little
things and it went from two good things
you know three good things
and it's just you know water i don't i
don't even know if it's true
i don't know if it's true but it's got
to be better than drinking [ __ ] sodas
all day yeah anything is better than
drinking six or seven cans of coke that
i did without even blinking an eye i
could drink seven or six cans of coke
from [ __ ] eight in the morning to six
at night easy oh it's easy it's the most
delicious thing in the world with
chinese food with a cheeseburger with
ice cubes in it stop it joint in the
[ __ ] trunk
i love that's the one thing i really
need to to
cut down on i've cut way down on it i
used to have maybe seven or eight a day
now i've cut cut back to two or three
diet sodas in a day which isn't great
but it's um i do notice days i have more
soda than water i don't lose weight i
feel like it holds even diet yeah
because it has high sodium yeah i feel
like it holds under the water so i'm
trying to do that thing the thing your
parents make you do if you want the soda
to have a have at least that the same
amount of water first
just to try it
i'm always going to love soda i can cut
it out if i want to but
i've cut it back to
pretty recently you're 26 years old yeah
i'm not sitting here no [ __ ] high
horse i stopped drinking soda when i was
like 45.
that's when i made the decision i wish
i would have made the decision on your
age that would have saved pounds well
that's why i'm working out now it's
because i used it at night i don't drink
alcohol yeah so i would drink you know
let me get a coke let me get a coke let
me get a coke what are you drinking a
coke coke coke first because the free
refills yeah free refills you're doing
18 [ __ ] cokes do the math that you
know whatever 120 [ __ ] calories you
know if you drink 20 cans of for 20 of
those glasses at 100 calories 90
calories yeah what the [ __ ] you you know
i got very lucky that for and it wasn't
a weight thing i just always
leaned towards diet coke it was regular
coke is a little bit too sweet but i
can't imagine
trying to cut that out because that's
like you said let's see let's see you
have just one with every meal that's an
extra
400 calories you have to cut out
that's i mean it's hard 400 calories
takes half an hour on the elliptical
it's a lot do it on the [ __ ] bicycle
you're they're all [ __ ] they running
400 goddamn
like that i love the bike i love going
for my knee and stuff like that but
after 20 minutes you go
i just blew 20 minutes for [ __ ] 60
calories or whatever the [ __ ] i burned
68 calories or something [ __ ] so i had a
pass on that but everything's good the
knee i got a physical therapy tomorrow
are you worried about it with uh with
with your daughter because i don't know
about terry's family but i mean are you
worried about watching what she eats now
that she's eating more regularly yes
especially no sodas a lot in my house
okay there's no cans you know there's
juices for her and there's
water my wife cuts the juices
so she doesn't have that much sugar you
know
you just want to correct little things
it's very easy for a child now it's like
my friend he says this kid only eats
chicken nuggets
so they have to buy chicken fry and
batter them so they don't eat that white
[ __ ] they give you what everybody says
they have white meat but it's really
like painted somebody told me it's bad
they painted white i don't [ __ ] know
you know but i don't put anything past
these people anymore right you know you
don't put anything past these people
it's amazing uh
a friend of terry's
uh him and his wife used to come over he
was a bike rider he just got diagnosed
with cancer
uh he got you know the the
colon cancer okay one of those cancers
not colon but the other one that getting
when you don't stick a finger up your
ass
i thought it was cool
i know you're talking about uh
and i was talking to him today you know
we were talking about what changes he
made he's not getting chemo he's pulling
what my uncle did he's not getting chemo
he's not getting the treatment he's
going to mexico for a new experimental
thing
so changing it to an organic
uh listen man my uncle's 78 he's had
cancer for two years prostate cancer is
working prostate and he's rocking and
rolling he changed his diet he doesn't
touch sugar i mean he spends so much
money on special foods
he goes everywhere just to buy a certain
like that neither dodger game he brought
some little dried up [ __ ] apple i'd
like to get the name of it and it's the
highest oxy accidents whatever the [ __ ]
it is yeah he brought almonds these
organic almonds he always
you know and i don't know if it works
i'm not here you know i'm not like this
guy this guy rode a bike
from uh whoever 20 miles from here north
to downtown every day so he would ride
the bike 20 miles from here to the bus
over here in north hollywood then put
the bike on the bus for half the thing
then get back on the
you know and now he goes up he's been
there's a guy that rides 50 miles on the
weekends he's got [ __ ] prostate
cancer
you know so it's true they have to check
it out you know you have to do the
finger in the butt i got it i got it
three or four times it's not [ __ ] it
just it just scares me when people say
they don't want to do chemo and trust me
i know key mode isn't uh guaranteed and
i know it it hurts people it's it's
because it's putting poison in your body
but whenever i see that i'm like
ah that why are you taking a chance on
the new treatments
listen man they do a lot of things
outside this country that are very
beneficial that we don't get the chance
to do okay because of the way politics
and the medical systems assurances i
don't i don't know the bureaucracy so
please do not attack me i'm just saying
that i've heard this you know when you
watch the dallas buyers club whether
they talk he's a smuggler he brings in
pills that'll stop or whatever the hiv
virus or neutralize it that aren't
available here that the fda will not
pass
so
uh true doctors doctors get together put
a purse together go to the fda and say
he's a million dollars don't pass that
drug because we're out of business
you know you pass that [ __ ] drug
we're out of [ __ ] business that's
also true yeah so i don't know how it
works i'm not accusing anybody of
anything i don't want people tweeting me
like they're saying joey you're wrong
speaking of doctors what are you going
to dallas anytime soon why what happened
you didn't hear this [ __ ] guy
came from liberia and walking around
dallas for a week with ebola
dallas is like the [ __ ] worst luck in
the world
a kennedy won't even go to texas
never mind dallas that's where they shot
kennedy right yeah and now ebola's in
[ __ ] dallas michael irvin it's just
bad luck dallas is just [ __ ] bad luck
man that's what forget it i'm going to
houston and i love dallas but now that
the bowlers did i heard they sent them
home from the hope from the hospital
that first day yeah the first day he
went coughing and shaking hands and
jumping up and down eating [ __ ] at
the soul food restaurant you know how
many [ __ ] people gonna get sick now
eight nine i guess his kid he was close
to kids his girlfriend's kids yeah yeah
this is i know this is gonna happen it's
just a [ __ ] you know we're not smart
enough to close it nobody oh you're from
the united states and liberia go [ __ ]
yourself he's not even american i know
no no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no [ __ ] you
know
listen bro every day more and more we're
slipping but this is not what this
podcast is about [ __ ] them they do what
they do they keep slipping and we keep
[ __ ] [ __ ] but at least it was over in
atlanta i was it was they were just
keeping it in atlanta
it's already in that way i already don't
like knocking downhouses they're already
spreading it all over the [ __ ] place
this is their mate this is it this is
what they want bro
this is what they want they got it you
didn't know to shut that [ __ ] airport
you didn't know nobody knew they shut
that [ __ ] airport
if you're african you ain't coming
nowhere you ain't going nowhere that's
it [ __ ] visas ripped up if you're
[ __ ] african
and it's not i don't hate africans i'm
just telling you the truth this is what
anybody anybody smart would have done
until we find out what the [ __ ] going
on in that bigger yeah nobody's coming
in out of [ __ ] after you're in africa
who's pitching tent [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] tent cut sucker don't worry
there's no isis [ __ ] they don't kill
black people they haven't killed a
mexican or black people a chinese
[ __ ] person yet isis because the only
gentiles that sit there waiting for
their neck to get checked are these
[ __ ] momos a black [ __ ] is
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'm getting mine you
think i just kneel there and wait like a
[ __ ] rabbit to get hooked by a hawk
yeah are you [ __ ] crazy i'm at least
getting up and getting an eyeball in
here something i'm going to kick
somebody in the nuts real [ __ ] hard
but you think so i'd bite that [ __ ]
dick right off i don't give away you're
going to cut my head off there's 80
years i'm going to take one of you i
know i can take one of your
[ __ ] until you stab me i'll
grab your [ __ ] head ball i stick my
fingers in your eyes i'm a [ __ ] nut
you know me i hate ebola
i hate [ __ ] a bowl and all that [ __ ]
i've been telling you people from the
beginning i knew this was going to
happen
that's it we're done and how long does
it take from [ __ ]
uh
if you walk the [ __ ] ebola to
california it'll still be in two weeks
if you walk it if you gave liberia boy a
[ __ ] backpack and some roller skates
he'd be in two [ __ ] weeks
i'm sick i'm sick of myself that's quite
an image like i'm just a black dude from
liberia and just roller skating
foaming at the [ __ ] mouth that's what
i need
betty page triple x you sexy
[ __ ]
hey
how you doing what's up
you know it well
welcome to the church what's happening
now lee syed's here hi betty it was it
was very hi how's it going this is lee
the uh the producer of the show
wait nice to meet you
nice to meet you it's i've heard a lot
about you
so a couple weeks ago the main man the
fearless leader dennis hoff was on the
show
gotta love big daddy we gotta love big
daddy and he told us about some of his
girls and you're one of the sexy ones he
spoke about and next you know we became
friends on twitter and here you are and
we got some questions for you
yeah
so how is it working up at the ranch
oh it's freaking awesome every day is
like a party
um you get to meet some really
interesting people it's just everything
is going 24 7. but they've got some
places over there too where if you want
it quiet and relaxed they've got some
sleeps over there and hot tubs and
jacuzzis and the pool i mean it's it's
like disneyland for adults it's really
cool
well they're going to be shutting those
jacuzzis down because ebola has [ __ ]
landed
and we don't know those pretty girls
foaming at the mouth looking like
[ __ ] walking dead
uh how long have you worked up there
beautiful
what's that how long have you worked up
there
i actually i haven't worked up there for
too long i've only worked up there since
about june and then i blew up i was the
bunny of the month in august
oh my god
another one now it was crazy now when
does the show does the show still shoot
or
no um which one because we do a ustream
show every week nothing is awesome i
mean i just posted um um let me see i
was like doing the computer stuff
because we do chat and everything and
roof rap was over there too not too long
ago that's katy perry's boyfriend and
got pictures of that too that was a
blast
riffraff is that his name kelly perry's
boyfriend
yeah that's his name who's riffraff
who's this freaking
crazy as hell he's got like pink hair
and he's like crazy blue eyes it looks
like he's dead
it's crazy wrong with katy perry
katy perry you know she don't suck dick
you know you know she don't take it in
the ass you know she don't do none of
that [ __ ] and she keeps teaming up with
these [ __ ] savages and wanna [ __ ] her
to death while she's singing
and uh then she gets pissed off when
they want to come in her [ __ ] eyeball
she's like you know what i'm saying you
could tell
it's like jennifer anderson you could
tell she won't grab a cop it's like
jennifer grab that [ __ ] dragon
[ __ ] this ain't friends [ __ ]
breathe on that [ __ ]
yeah fun for the whole family no one the
[ __ ] brad pitt left you for that
dirty [ __ ]
you wouldn't let him pop it up
she wouldn't let him [ __ ] stick her
finger up her ass he said [ __ ] it this
uh what's in the angelina jolie she'll
let you light her [ __ ] on fire and turn
it off with a rock
just throw rocks at it
that's how good
you could just throw rocks at her
[ __ ] [ __ ] to turn off the fire she
don't give a [ __ ] jack
now when you go back to the bunny race
now when do you go back to the bunny
ranch
um i was actually i may be going back
for thanksgiving just to say hi and
everything but definitely i'm going back
the whole month of february and the
whole month of march
because i'm tearing the club up
so once again when does your tour of
duty start in february you go back to
vietnam for the monkey
that's like right that's like vietnam
for the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the bunny ranch you go up there you get
shot [ __ ]
kicked it's tremendous [ __ ]
as long as i get beat with a stick i'm
happy i love it
we got two sticks right over here
[ __ ] lee's got the
some tybo sticks he got some some fine
[ __ ] aging
now when did you get started in the uh
entertainment business let's say
let's see there was a while back i was
dancing in west virginia because i live
in virginia but i was dancing over in
west virginia and funny enough i was
watching one of the cat house series and
there was this girl just popping
balloons with her ass and i was sitting
back i was like i could do that i could
pop a balloon with my ass
so i went online and i applied just like
everybody else i put my pictures in i'm
like i'm not gonna hear back from them
they don't want me next thing you know
sure enough they're like we think you're
beautiful we think you'll be great here
and i was like no [ __ ] oh my god so i
was like you know what [ __ ] it you only
live once popped on a plane went over
tried it out and i was like wow
it was unfreaking believable it was like
a dream come true
so the first time you went over and
tried it out how many days did you stay
there for
two weeks because you got to stay at
least two weeks
so i stayed actually no that's a lie i
see them up did you cry at all the first
night like summer camp
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
i only cried when i didn't have enough
dick that was it beautiful that's why i
[ __ ] love you you felt the animal
now
okay
so you stayed there for a month and that
was the first time you had been on that
side of the fence or you had played on
that side of the fence before
well i started actually at um another
ranch over by vegas okay and that place
was like [ __ ] prison that was a
lockdown house you could not do anything
over there and no fun at all no fun
so i tried it over there a little bit
and i never did anything illegally
before but i had a lot of freaking
boyfriends if you know what i mean right
so you said what the [ __ ]
yeah exactly i was like i might as well
get paid for my [ __ ] you know it's
amazing uh betty when i was 21 i used to
live in aspen colorado and i used to
walk around
and i you know and i have nothing
against women i i love women to do
whatever they want with their bodies
it's their world you know and i always
said i go if i was pretty girl at 21 i
would come to action
i would charge
[ __ ] paper to [ __ ] me i take care of
my [ __ ] take care of my titties
i keep my teeth white you know the whole
[ __ ] deal and i [ __ ] up the ass
whatever you want for four years
and when i turn uh-huh and then i i go
on the witness relocation plan after
that i go into places
i change my name and i'd moved somewhere
with my [ __ ]
uh half a million or my three quarters
of a million
and i would start my life and nobody
would know nobody would ever know
like if you were that's the thing too i
love that people know me i'm like yeah
i'm such and such and i also go by betty
page my family knows what i do they
support me they're proud of me
i'm no no i don't mean it like that i
mean like
just
if you just want to forget
when you're
one pack you get money and you go you
know what it's something i did a long
time ago it worked for me then now i
work in an office whatever i'm a mom now
i'm a pta girl
nobody needs to know that you uh rocked
the house for three years and made month
because in the long run what are you
gonna do what the [ __ ] do you do from 21
to 26 if you're hot you get [ __ ] you
get dennis thrown down your throat and
on top of all that these [ __ ] morons
are still going to cheat on you
you follow me it's high protein i want
it down my throat yeah you know they're
still gonna [ __ ] cheat or whatever
you know what [ __ ] a boyfriend [ __ ] with
that get a guy you see him once a month
again he doesn't even have to know what
the [ __ ] you do
you can't tell him you're a scientist
in a [ __ ] uh in a martian resort in
vegas where the martians landed you
check rocks all day yeah they don't need
to [ __ ] know julian cat house
now when you go home after the bunny
ranch do you still entertain or are you
do you give that monkey a breather
um actually i've got a really high sex
drive so i'm always feeding for it i got
all kinds of like lilo toys and
everything and accidents and all kinds
of things
i'm even going
it looks like almost like a horse battle
and that whole freaking horse saddle
just vibrates like you wouldn't believe
and it has attachments to it and a
remote control i mean it's like it's
it's just freaking [ __ ] it's awesome and
you stick it and you stick it in guys
[ __ ]
well i could do that too usually i ride
it and then i'll stick something off the
guy or i can even just do a little
finger or just lick it a little bit
because i've got this huge oral fixation
okay
this is what i am known for i love oral
because when i please a guy i take my
time it's like
going to dinner and having dessert you
spread the guy open you kiss all around
everywhere and there is not just a dick
in his chest oh i'm sorry can i can i
say hi you could say whatever the [ __ ]
you want to say this is this is fcc
we're best friends with the fcc the fcc
loves us
okay well basically what i like to do i
like to spread them open
and i like to lick from the thighs
getting my way inside
then i'll kind of like nibble and just
right there on the balls back a little
bit
lift them up and i love that little
grundle part right between the [ __ ]
and the balls because that's where the
prostate is and that [ __ ]
that'll get them going every time you
just comb your ass off and lick right
there
then
you suck on some balls just a little bit
work your way up then you start with the
tip and work your way down it is a whole
smorgasbord
and that's what i love about this [ __ ]
that's why i get paid the big bucks
because i don't just want to get you off
and get you out
you're my meal i'm gonna eat you alive
that's a good way of looking at it i
mean that's a positive way of looking i
love you for that that's uh
you know because then again you have a
lot of women that don't want to please
you you just want to [ __ ] go on with
their life then you meet a woman like
you or you i'm talking to a woman like
you and this is what you do you get paid
to [ __ ] make a man see [ __ ]
fireworks
that's between exactly i will pamper you
bathe you wash you lube you and then
wash you again definitely
it's all about the experience
that's uh that's a nice [ __ ] time you
sound like a very very very very nice
time
you watch me yeah
we [ __ ] we eat some ass
then we relax we watch a little episode
of dancing with the stars
and then we go right back to eating that
ass again and licking balls and
fireworks lee what questions you got
from my beautiful girl betty paige i
just can't what do you do you make the
guys at least wash themselves before you
look at our [ __ ] because i can't i
know what my [ __ ] smells like and i
don't want anything sure she makes them
wash themselves a nice bath then you
just see she
she does it to make sure because she's
going to fall
i do both i send them into the shower i
let them wash up and everything so that
they get comfortable then i lay them
down on the bed and then i'll double
wash them and that kind of gets the mood
going too you don't just like wham bam
like you're spreading jelly and you know
peanut butter and [ __ ] you actually kind
of do like the peter pan before and
afterwards do you have like industrial
soap because there's not enough irish
spring
to ever
make this i can never imagine a girl
doing that to me
will make it happen for you betty page i
got to ask you some more questions here
uh what's the craziest thing a customer
has asked you to do if you're allowed to
talk about this if not i understand i
want no problems with mr hoff oh hell
yeah i never um i've never seen names
but i will definitely talk about my
adventures because they're fun what's
the craziest thing a guy has come in and
made you do like a guy came in and said
listen i'm gonna throw 10 000 on you
i want you to [ __ ] shoot your [ __ ]
at me and knock me down i don't know
uh let me see i think the craziest so
far i don't get too too crazy just yet
but then again i like crazy so some
stuff that people will do
you know normal people think it's crazy
i'm like hell yeah let's try it let's do
it but i think one of the craziest ones
so far is um i haven't been asked to do
a poop party but i have had a guy want
me to pee on him
that's not bad i put him in his bathtub
and i did it
and did he go did he cut did he come did
he get off
oh yeah yeah oh yeah when they peed on
me
i didn't get off i had never been peed
on before so it opened my [ __ ] eyes
in more ways than one i mean that'd be
[ __ ] tremendous
it tasted good it wasn't that bad you
know
i didn't come but i always thought about
it i'm like man that's a good way to
maybe while she's peeing on you you get
somebody to put a feather up your
[ __ ] and you work off with your left
hand
jesus does [ __ ] like that you know what
i'm saying that's a jesus that's jesus
yeah
oh another one too i had two there was
this guy that came and um he basically
wanted me to be his mistress so i did
and he did a little bit of foot worship
while i decorated him i walked him
around the parlor and everything
and um basically just made him call me
mr betty the whole time and
had a really great time and he got off
that way he really had a good time now
how long do you stay with a man usually
when they come up to the ranch what's
the minimum time they could spend with
you
the minimum time they can spend with me
is uh probably 10 minutes and it's not
going to be a very fulfilling 10 minutes
i'll tell you that but that is the
minimum i try to help out every budget
that i can because i enjoy what i do so
i want people to come and not do
anything and just leave that's not fun
so you gotta do a little bit of
something
what do you because you must be you're
obviously a proponent of all this what
do you say to a guy like me or like to
my girlfriend like what would you like
how do you
sell it because if i went and told a
girl that i did this a lot of them would
probably have negative reactions like
how how do you look at it how do you how
do you
how do you do it so it's not a negative
experience
oh well that's easy
basically when you come and you see me
or even any girl at the ranch um you're
actually getting educated you're not
just seeing a professional
which you know that you'll be clean you
know that um is not going to follow you
home or do anything crazy or try to stop
you or you know anything like that but
also you're getting somebody that's
going to educate you on what works what
doesn't work and you can bring that to
another girl i've actually had gentlemen
that you know
either they were virgins or they weren't
that experienced and they wanted to
please another lady and they were
insecure and you can't just watch porn
and get educated on it so they basically
come to me and say will you be my
teacher
and even if they don't say that just
from the stuff that we do
we're going to have fun and you're going
to see that i like it because i don't
think anything i'm going to get off if
this is my job and i've got to be with
you and you've got to be with me we're
both having some fun
but why do you think that is though
because there's other countries that
have totally legalized it and it's not
looked down upon why do you think that
that it's only legal in one part of one
state now and it's it's in most people
it's probably probably looked down upon
um well basically it's only legal in
that state and only in a couple counties
because it's grandfathered in um
you know as
i don't know i think that we just have a
hard time really changing if you look at
it
70s was the era of free love finally but
all the way before that we've had
decades and centuries of just being
complete prudes and saying that sex was
wrong
and
even after the 70s we kind of went back
to the whole just family unit and
everything is very quiet inside the
bedroom now again nowadays we're just
starting to get out again
and really explore sexuality and say hey
it's not wrong for me to feel good and
you're feeling good and everybody is so
pathetic it's a natural human condition
we all need to be touched we all need to
feel love and feel looked back and
you know we all go to the senses we all
get our hair done nails done we go to
the barber
and all that kind of good stuff we even
go to the gym this is exercise massage
and the spa all in one
it's healthy
i've never
when a girl has told me that that's what
she does for a living
in the back of my mind i've never looked
down on her i've looked at it as a
more of a liberated woman
you know uh-huh i mean parts of it a
little bit more liberating well i think
the reason people look down upon it is
is self freedom yeah well it's like i
don't i look at it as when you look at a
hey listen
a woman may have kids she might have had
a child and she doesn't get along with
the husband and whatever she has to do
to feed that child
if she's beautiful whether whatever is
beauty whatever's beauty to a man
they're all beautiful
what what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i've never looked down on
it like that you know yeah you meet some
dancers [ __ ] crazy but i gotta tell
you something from my uh conversations
with you betty and
you're very intelligent you're very
intelligent you know what's going on
you're on the ball
you're sharp you know you're just not
doing this because uh
you're not doing this because you know
you want to be cool and you know you do
this for a [ __ ] living this is a
business for you and you're the best at
what the [ __ ] you do you know if you
just want some chick to suck your dick
and whatever and then you get out of a
hotel room that's one thing going to you
is like going to spark steakhouse
it's like going with [ __ ] ruth chris
it's like going to
you know i don't know all the five-star
restaurants but it's like it's like
driving a [ __ ] maserati you know i
understand what you're saying
yeah you know and it's the truth we've
all been with women that
are kind of uh reclusive and we try to
push them a little bit and they crack
and then you bring women home that'll
you know hit their [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] hammer if you let them you know
and
and you think of who you've had a better
time with
every [ __ ] man that listening to this
right now who'd you have better time
the chick that does her toenails and
lays there like a [ __ ] mummy because
she doesn't want you to think wrong
or the chick that turns around and says
after you [ __ ] me the [ __ ] i want you
to stick it in my ass like a [ __ ]
you know i don't even know like you're
stuffing me for thanksgiving
and then i want you to pull it out and
give me some of that you who milk in my
mouth or something well it's the worst i
mean betty said at the beginning she's
very oral i i can't tell you i wanted a
girl the first time we were going to
have sex just look at me and say don't
go down there because i don't i don't do
it
oh my god god no no no no oh
oh that is terrible i really feel bad
for girls that say that it's like oh my
god bill just open it up close your eyes
and let him have fun
no it's true
it's true if you look as a man who have
you had most fun with the chicks that
are [ __ ] crazy yeah you can't marry
those [ __ ]
you know that's somewhere that's
somewhere gonna affect you but you look
at that you want somebody in the middle
of that to have a relationship with when
i see betty i go to betty to get me
[ __ ] lubed up
you know you go see betty watch someone
even if you sling dick for three weeks
you go see betty to put you right back
in shape betty's like a sexual
chiropractor she snaps those bones she
aligns your [ __ ] your nuts align with
your dick you know betty does the whole
[ __ ] name so i get it betty i [ __ ]
get it
actually i've been with straight men
i've been with gay men i've been with
couples even gay men love me i mean i
spot the gay man so hard and he was
happy he actually came back for more i
had couples come with me for their
anniversary and they had the time of
their lives and it was great because we
got to do all kinds of stuff it's not
just about the guys it's about the girls
and it's great when they come in with a
couple because i can show the guys other
things that they haven't been doing to
the kick and when the girl gets off and
we're all having fun it's like the guy
can have as many orgasms as he wants he
can like have multiple orgasms and
everything because the chicks are just
going at it it's a lot of fun
that's really uh
that's [ __ ] crazy the fact came in
and you changed his [ __ ] life
can you imagine like yeah you know he
was a doctor
did you lick his nutsack too
did he say to you that you're better
than a guy or that guy's a better that's
[ __ ] hysterical if he said you know
what betty you're pretty good but i know
this guy named mike
that sucks he was impressed
[ __ ] hysterical
now let me ask you this so once you go
back in march in february
now the girls work there year round or
you're forced to take a break
um it basically depends because working
over there is sort of like going to a
sorority house when you go there you
always have to like change out rooms and
stuff and it depends what's available
um because they've got so many girls
there i mean it's really
it's really exclusive to be a bunny babe
so to be a bunny babe is like the top
notch of the whole world
but they do have like a lot of girls on
call and everybody wants to be there and
they do try to give new girls an
opportunity so it really depends on
if they have availability if you know
their schedule is open if you do really
good like you know i've got a really
good clientele then they're going to let
you come in
but it really depends on what's
available and what's open but as far as
going over there i mean you've got girls
that'll stay there for a few months at a
time
uh some that'll stay for like a week or
two
it really depends
it's uh
it's an amazing thing when he came down
and explained it to us and i've watched
the shows it was very uh
very entertaining and very
eye-opening because i you know
i know about drugs i know about mugging
people i know about crime i know about
so many things and i don't know anything
about that sex world
when uh
you know i thought i knew about
everything we all think we know about
everything when i was
31 i started dating this girl and one
day
after about three months she pulls me
aside she goes i don't know if you know
this when i was in college i had sugar
daddy
and i told i looked through my face and
i go you know what i ate a couple sugar
daddies all the time and she's like what
are you talking about
i didn't know where the sugar daddy was
and she told me that he put it through
school and he [ __ ] it once a week
and he used to pay all her bills and
everything and i was blown away like
i had never heard of those things like
here i was
like again i thought i knew a little bit
about everything and she was telling me
all this stuff and
i talked to her today as a matter of
fact uh she's 46
and she's still stripping and she's a
millionaire
and she's a millionaire because she
married this old hindu when he died and
left her like 3 million then she bought
a bunch of gyms
those curves
and she sold them on the way on the high
end so she made money there
she buys all this [ __ ] problem
yeah but it's uh it's weird like you
know she kept you know she until today
now she tells me the truth i mean she's
engaged to be married
and she gives blow jobs for 100 and she
[ __ ] you for 200 at the strip club this
is a girl that's a [ __ ] millionaire
oh that's really low it's it's i mean i
don't know anything about that no [ __ ]
no [ __ ] no this is well this is what i'm
saying to you that you could either go
get let her suck your dick or you could
take a train to the plane and go see my
girl betty paige up at the bunny ranch
bunny of the month and she'll show you
what it's all about let me ask you this
when you were 20 did you ever think
you'd be doing this
when i was what 20.
uh no i really didn't i never
said you know
well when i was younger actually i
always wanted to be three things
i wanted to be a playboy bunny and i
didn't know why because i was too young
at the time i was like about eight
and i wanted to be a playboy bunny only
because people thought they were pretty
i wanted to be a navy seal because we
got to swim around with the sharks naked
and then i wanted to be wonder woman
because she's hard to tell and she can
kick ass
so basically it's kind of like
pre-ordained digestion that i was
to be a bunny i never actually thought
that i would do anything like this but
i've always been a little nuts and it's
like let's go have a good time and when
all these other girls are starting to be
kurdish and like no no we can't do this
we can't do that i'm like
[ __ ] you i'm going over here whoa let's
get this party started
now when has there ever been a chick
that goes up like were you at the bunny
ranch did you see a girl like on her
first day
you know she's like the hot girl at the
strip club in kansas city
and she goes up there and all of a
sudden they throw do they throw like a
[ __ ] black dude with a 30 inch dick
just a house walmart so she just to see
if she breaks under pressure like the
[ __ ] she comes out of there
[ __ ] running you know or she comes
out with a big smile on her face that's
what i would do
before she could do anything i gotta
she's gotta [ __ ] my goomba
the black dude from liberia with the
ebola and if she rocks his [ __ ]
if she rocks his [ __ ] world
if she doesn't no have you ever been up
there when the girl's come out of the
room crying and says she's can't do this
have you ever had that experience
no no basically they're really mommy
mommy is madame susan she is awesome she
is really good about screening the girls
she basically talks to him the reason i
call her mommy is because she's not just
the madam she really looks out for her
girls and if she doesn't think you have
what it takes she's not gonna let you
stay there or anything because it's a
business and you know you want to please
the clients as well as to make money
yourself and get pleased
and if you're too scared or anything
like that and you don't have a hunger
for it there's no reason for you to be
there
but usually whenever the first girl gets
there we're all pretty nice and
usually you you always get a big sister
and a big sister
is really hot in itself because the big
sister will help you along the way by
teaching you the rules
teaching you how to negotiate going into
the room with the customer your first
few times making sure you got it down
and maybe even partying with you just to
make sure that you're doing everything
that you should be doing
wow so they'll come in the room with
your first couple times
uh-huh
that's pretty [ __ ] so that's how you
get on on-the-job training or were you
that good when you already went to you
were good already when you went to the
bunny ranch they just [ __ ] made your
[ __ ] tight
your fingers get manicured now the whole
[ __ ] deal you don't have no more hang
nails
it's over no
no they really did make my [ __ ] tight
too because there are some other things
i learned from some of the other girls
here and there that we caught each other
and there was a little move that i know
how to make it really tight and there's
two things you can do you can either
make it so tight where the dick is
actually going inside you more or you
can make it tight where you're pushing
him out
that is hot so you can have like the
whole section of either going inside
more or outside it's awesome
that's amazing you are
a true professional let me ask you this
when uh
has there ever been a guy that came in
that you really haven't liked and you've
had to sleep with them for the money and
but you're really not not that you're
attracted to him but
you just don't like him has there ever
been that situation like he's rude or
he's uh no
real and i'll tell you why i'll tell you
why because there have been um a couple
of guys
that very few very few that come in
there and they're rude or they're just
not nice or there's even no chemistry
and
i'm
i'm really serious about what i do
so if i don't like you
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you i don't care how
much money you have
you can stick it up your [ __ ] and
walk the [ __ ] out because
i mean it's about having a good time and
i want to make sure that everybody that
comes to me has the best experience in
their life
so if i can't give you a good time i'll
either send you to a friend of mine that
can or i'll just tell you look there's
no chemistry we're not going to get
along and it's not worth you spending
your money i would go to
some girl at a bar or just a hole in a
tree and pound it out because
i want to make sure that you're going to
have the best time ever with me and if
we don't mesh and you don't have a good
time i'm not going to take your money
because i don't want to take advantage
of you and if you're an [ __ ] i'm
definitely not going to have a good time
with you i might beat the [ __ ] out of
you but we're not going to have a good
time
that's as [ __ ] honest as it gets you
know i mean what you do is very rough uh
not rough and you know it's whatever you
make it in this life i mean i know
people exactly i know people would dig
ditches for a living that tell you to
have a great job you know
they look at the beauty of it i get in
shape
i can eat what i want you know i'm 50. i
know a guy that digs ditches he has a
[ __ ] thing and then he has to get in
there for a foot and clean it out with a
shovel you know it's not just
and it's and he makes it sound he's been
doing it since high school
they give him [ __ ] 50 grand a year
because they usually had two guys and he
does everything by himself and you know
he's my age digging and building up
rocks and so it's whatever you make of
your job you know if you don't like your
job obviously you're not going to be
effective at it
or whatnot yeah that's exactly it so you
won't be up there for december or
november or nothing for the holidays
give away that holiday [ __ ] nothing
no no i might be up there for like uh
thanksgiving week but i'm not sure yet i
still gotta see what my schedule is but
i know i'm definitely gonna be there all
of february and all of march because
february is my birthday too february
what
22nd
the same as junior serving i think
or the 23rd something like that i'm the
19th
nice
i think unite that's right i'm the first
[ __ ] day of the cuss betty page i
love you
we're gonna try to get you in studio
here in november or december we'll
figure something out
before you go before you go up to the
ranch and break some [ __ ] hearts you
have a guy coming over with a little
little dick what do you do then like a
one inch dick what do you do like
you tell him it's [ __ ] huge you [ __ ]
sucker don't ever come in here with this
big dick again
i [ __ ] hum the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
that's what i do
some little japanese comes one of those
little peanut dicks you rock that
[ __ ]
chunk
chunk kennedy's cousin [ __ ] comes in
i eat a tic-tac like you wouldn't
believe
betty paige i love you thank you very
much and we'll talk during the week you
sexy [ __ ]
all right and how do they find you how
do they know your web page
right what's the webpage my webpage is
betty page um
or even my my email email me because i
love talking to people it's studypage
bunnyranch.com and my twitter i'm on the
twitter all the time it's ready page
triple x
and i'm even on facebook steady page
with two exes
go to her twitter she got some nice big
[ __ ] jugs her feet everything she's a
sexy [ __ ]
i love you betty page you dirty [ __ ] i
love you i love you papi stay black
are you like that lisa at least i had
when she was saying licking balls your
face was [ __ ] pale
no looking balls i like the [ __ ] the
blood in your body went right to your
[ __ ] dick don't lie to me your dick
is harder than [ __ ] right now oh god
i've seen your little hand doing
cornucopias i kind of wish i went when i
was uh because i was single for like two
years i kind of wish i had done that to
just get the experience like i still
think i'd be so [ __ ] embarrassed oh
yeah of course that i mean i haven't
even been so [ __ ]
when i was in that testosterone last
year i walked around so [ __ ] horny
and i would go to that massage parlor
down the block from the
uh haha yeah and park down the block
just to see just to see if i could do it
maybe if a girl pops out i could see her
and talk to her i didn't have the heart
i'd have to cheat on my wife and i have
the heart to go in and get a [ __ ]
hand job i just can't i just think it's
so [ __ ] embarrassing sometimes you
know yeah i can i come real quick and
[ __ ] i gotta look at you
sit there and [ __ ] i go to that bunny
ranch i come in a minute they're all
gonna look at me and they're gonna tell
each other everybody knows i'm a [ __ ]
preemie let me give some shout outs to
these well you just told it to all the
listeners
i'm not [ __ ] them you know what i'm
saying zach corona happy birthday you
bad [ __ ] flo who loves you
matt floyd russell mcdonald
kayla simmons you bad [ __ ]
brandi lynn i love you
ronnie olson dan pazzini and my main man
jimmy pitts
debt squad all over the country death
squad charlotte that's why ottawa stay
strong [ __ ] you know what the
deal is
now what [ __ ] no i don't like about
girls tell me girls everything ones that
always say i love doing this i get to
meet interesting people listen i'm 51
[ __ ] years old and i still haven't
met nobody [ __ ] interesting you're
the most interesting [ __ ] person i
know because you're jewish
hey so the jews are still shooting
missiles in them
i honestly don't i don't uh i don't
think they have issues but i don't think
they're i think they sound like a
missile once a month to let them know
the captain kirk of the enterprise is
your [ __ ] you got to do that sometimes
we don't hear about the russians
shooting down planes no more the
russians hate malaysians you know they
shot two of those [ __ ] planes down at
least the first one that disappeared the
guy went to sleep
they were looking at the terrorism the
[ __ ] russians shot that [ __ ]
down and they radiated that [ __ ] they
never even found the [ __ ] tire not a
piece of luggage nothing yeah you think
they find something nothing who gots
nothing
so next wednesday we're at the [ __ ]
ice uh lice house next wednesday we're
at the long beach laugh factory
and we're trying to put a a podcast
together with a show we're going down
tomorrow night
to uh look at the things for cameras
they have like a screen that pops down
this will be like a new age type podcast
we'll do down there yeah that'd be cool
so let's go take a look tomorrow night
so that's that's it's pretty i've been
thinking about that all day how we can
make that live podcast really [ __ ]
kicking down there matt fultron's coming
down really yeah i'm at full time tom
segura might show up
i got [ __ ] uh duncan trussell if he
gets back i think he gets back before
the eighth
he's on tour right now doing podcast
tour really with some guy yeah i think
he's in portland oregon or something
well he's really making it happen duncan
all these guys i spoke to harry harry's
in london
charlie helen over there [ __ ] fish
and chips you called him yeah i called
him the other your phone bill is going
to be [ __ ] good what's the [ __ ]
that's brother it's my brother oh my god
i'm unlimited sprint i call [ __ ]
malaysia okay i could call [ __ ]
african tell those librarians to don't
go nowhere
suck my dick you got a flu but it's it's
pretty cool talking uh for people who
don't know we just we just hit 10
million downloads uh on just itunes and
this is all because of you guys so it's
pretty much three years you know
you know we like doing these ourselves
because we can tell you what's going on
in our mind sometimes so we're our own
[ __ ] guest tonight for you people
that at home smoking dope having a good
time you know i'm saying jumping up and
[ __ ] down this might be the first
podcast that they masturbated to
betty page i know i was a good one betty
pays don't [ __ ] hey she showed up at
the show she's very pretty she didn't
act like a [ __ ] jerk off you know
most girls in that position she's a
beautiful girl with gigantic tits a
great body and they flaunt it she hit it
you know uh people were checking her out
she's a pretty girl and i just thought
it'd be interesting for you guys to get
that perspective you know i would
usually have her in the morning but [ __ ]
who cares it's wednesday night
[ __ ] get your [ __ ] together and
[ __ ] she doesn't wake up early she has
to recover from the last night she
sounds like she has fun every night and
talking about pain it's crazy because
my uh wife and i were watching bubble
guppy's time with the baby i had ice on
my knees great episode [ __ ]
tremendous
uh i don't know which one it was about
they opened up a pizza joint and [ __ ]
the baby was scared then we watched the
halloween one but i was talking about
how i got to go to you know i went to i
was telling her i told her today about
the pain when i went to jersey i didn't
realize i'm 51 and
i realize now that uh whenever i go back
there i feel that pain again it's going
to be also weird when i go back to
denver next week
oh wow yeah how long has it been
well you go every year seriously it's
been 19 years seriously
it's really been 19 years because when i
go to denver now i go very controlled
yeah i go i stay in denver i really
haven't seen boulder it's gotta be
13 years are you going back to boulder
yeah i'm gonna go to boulder on friday
morning friday afternoon and see some
friends and [ __ ] and then come back for
the show friday night i'm gonna go
to look at the places where i kidnap so
i'll tape all this for you people we'll
make a special matt flavors world just
to uh
you know just to show you the memory
with the [ __ ] story so you guys know
where it's at so that's going to be very
interesting is it snowing up there again
or no no but it could it could the
second week of october [ __ ] yeah in fact
i'm very surprised i didn't get a big
snowstorm in september or did they i
don't know i've been so busy i haven't
even touched base to see what's going on
with the weather they usually get one
huge
snowstorm in september like the day
before is 90 yeah and the day after the
snowstorm is like 65 with that foot snow
storm is just to let you know they're
like the jews just to let you know
mother nature hasn't forgotten about you
[ __ ] down below
so what when are you in denver
i leave next wednesday night after the
show i'm going right from long beach on
the red eye they have a late night red
eye so i'm gonna take it over there and
just uh do thursday friday and saturday
at the improv oh great
you know i don't even know i think it's
on west colfax or east colfax one of
those [ __ ] streets everyone has the
internet now yeah but it's funny how uh
i started really these kofax a bad
[ __ ] street or it was
20 years ago now with development i
don't know what it's like i've heard
people i've asked people and they said
still pretty [ __ ] bad down there but
i love denver i love that whole i can't
wait to eat some green chili i'm going
to put green chili on everything i'm
going to do some working out and then i
already had some people that reached out
one guys and helped me with my knee and
[ __ ] so
you know
listen man i'm looking forward to
traveling yeah i i also like seeing the
people from twitter oh it's amazing you
know it's just uh it's a great time you
know
this week i like this is my last week
home for like seven weeks wow i know you
don't care but are you gonna go and try
uh legal weed
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i know that you
know i don't give a [ __ ] illegal legal
illegal
you know me doug i'm going to smoke it
no matter what when i go to one of the
stores i'll probably go to one of the
stores i'll probably reach out hopefully
cheaper too i'm going to hit them up
tomorrow to do chiba to thursday
okay next thursday at the at the comedy
at the improv maybe we'll all get high
and do some cheebo cheese remember
having them come down
and give away some chiba chews and we'll
get [ __ ] up
i'm not gonna eat an edible for a while
now really yeah i'm pretty good right
because i just went through a bag of
gummies a bag of peanut butter brittles
and [ __ ] six weeks of doing uh so
kind with you here and getting [ __ ] up
is that a good enough reason no you're
slipping and especially after the other
night you got too [ __ ] up oh
you kept saying oh we bought the haha
like i was like i was leaning on the
parking meter forever you ate 22 jujubes
no i had one i had one red one six bucks
i saw you going for the [ __ ] no i didn't
oh but no that was uh that was a crazy
night but i can't i'm almost a little
bit disappointed in you why
because you're the you walk around
on four edibles every day and now you're
gonna take a break i'm gonna take a
little breath you gotta take a little
breather from time to time i took a
breather from reefer for like five six
months how come i don't get to say i
went into breather time did you take a
breather tonight well tonight but it's
because you decided i didn't decide you
could have an edible if you wanted you
didn't say you wanted one i got one in
my bag but you want to eat it now no
all right then [ __ ] then why are
you breaking my chopsticks my job it's
not your [ __ ] job
it's amazing uh
this [ __ ] kid breaking my balls cause
i didn't give him a [ __ ] edible can
you believe this he's like giving
somebody
last night i gave him another boy at 7
30. he looked at it for 10 minutes told
me oh
oh oh give me half of it don't bite it
and he would hide it over there i
guarantee there's still [ __ ] piece of
edible over there it's gone
there's not there's nothing no it's uh
trust me i can't imagine the amount that
you that you go through but it's i'm
just surprised you're taking a break no
i went to acupuncture she cleaned my
adrenals
she cut me and stuff so she goes you've
been eating a lot of [ __ ] lately i go
how do you know she goes i could smell
it so i said [ __ ] it oh that's when you
know you had too much i'll know tomorrow
if i'm going to the dodger game the
first world first playoff game friday
night with your uncle yeah my uncle said
he'd go he said [ __ ] the bar i'll close
it because my cousin's going to vegas to
celebrate his birthday so he didn't
really have somebody goes [ __ ] i'll just
show up at 11. so i'll know tomorrow if
i get the tickets they're expensive
but it's my uncle you know and i'm gonna
have a good time with him on friday i
mean i you know
i some something happened to me last
week when i went to that baseball game
what's that just it brought back
something that i had missed for a long
time i like baseball yeah i like
watching it i don't like jumping up and
down and saying score and you suck
umpire i don't like that [ __ ] i just
like sitting there watching it just the
way some people go fishing people say
sometimes people go fishing and they put
their thing in and it's very therapeutic
for them a very uh
what's the word i'm looking for you know
like they're like you know relaxing yeah
i did i i left there i thought i was
gonna be stressed out and i had such a
great time
listening to my uncle telling me why
black people can't hit the curve i was
[ __ ] dying you know but he's got that
baseball logic like you know most people
in denver like that night it was a great
game people leaving the seventh inning
it was [ __ ] embarrassing yeah how
many people were just getting up
gentiles just to go to the game to tell
people they went to the [ __ ] game
they weren't even there to be involved
to cheer they didn't care about the
dodgers and they wear the hats and the
[ __ ] t-shirts and they get up and
leave with the 17. my uncle was looking
at them i thought he was going to get up
and shoot them because he's like these
[ __ ] jerk offs this is when the game
gets good yeah and i'm one of those guys
i'm not gonna lie to you for a long time
i went to baseball games and left
because of no interest
after last week i sat and i'm like man
how many [ __ ] baseball games
did i go to as a child
sitting next to him reminding me of
sitting next to my mother at those
baseball games he was a lot more quieter
i mean he was 90 more [ __ ] quieter
than my mother would be but it was just
uh the cube score i imagine him keeping
no he didn't keep school no he knew he
knows a lot about [ __ ] baseball you
know he's 78 so he watches the team i
mean he told me the nationals the team
to beat
in the national league maybe yeah yeah
it's uh it's hard to keep track but i
love going to live games on tv
there's just so many games that it's a
little bit much but like last night and
tonight there's some good games on
because it's they're playing to get into
the playoffs
uh pittsburgh game the giants were
killing the pirates when i came let's
find out what happened the giants were
five nothing when i left but let's see
that should be over by now uh
oh yeah the giants killed them ain't
nothing
holy [ __ ]
yeah
so i mean it's uh trust me i i love the
red sox and stuff but
it's uh it's it's hard to get into it
but i understand what you're saying how
you have to because i know you you you
hate the traffic and and all and the
lines and stuff but if
i'm assuming you just like we're like
okay i'm gonna be in traffic i might as
well enjoy it with my uncle and not
worry about it
and it's cool that he had a good time uh
it's funny i i talk myself out of a lot
of things i know a lot of people do that
uh i'm one of them like today i had the
jiu jitsu pants on the knee pants i
taped my knee i taped my wrist i had the
t-shirt on i had the bag made
and i was talking to myself only jiu
jitsu yeah because something's gonna
happen the traffic i'm gonna lose my
parking spot it's amazing how your mind
puts negative thoughts and that's how i
am about everything before i leave the
house i give myself 50 reasons why i
should stay home
you know you're going to lose your
parking spot you're going to do this you
might you know and it's [ __ ]
mind-boggling how your mind works like
i'm surprised i don't suffer from
depression i know i suffer from a couple
issues but that's one of them that i'm
i'm basically
always like i thought that that night
would ari was gonna be painful because
the story and comedy central it was
[ __ ] easy i went down at 3 30 i was
home by four then i went back 10 o'clock
with you they picked us up what's so
hard about it it's usually you you it's
usually not as bad as you think i work
myself up you know and i know a lot of
people do that uh then i thought the
[ __ ] new york trip oh my god it's the
new york trip was easy as pie
it was easy it couldn't be any [ __ ]
easy you know i was dreading those two
weeks because i hadn't been on the road
for so long i was dreading those two
weeks and they were beautiful
now i'm looking forward to denver i'm
looking forward to baltimore i'm looking
forward to miami then i got a week off
you know so that's the uh
it's just amazing how i talk myself out
of this [ __ ]
you know i didn't work out monday
because i hurt my knees someone i got
off the plane i went to the y and i was
doing uh leg ups you have to strengthen
the knee okay and monday my legs roll up
a little bit you know and i was like i'm
not gonna work out and i shouldn't i oh
did i oh i went for a long walk okay
that's right that went for a long walk
and then i kept battling myself whether
i should work out i'm not working i
started giving myself reasons then by 11
o'clock i was pissed because i didn't go
to the gym and do the epileptic or
whatever the [ __ ] it is right today i
went to jiu jitsu but yesterday when i
went to dr amy she told me that
acupuncture goes i'm happy it didn't
work out today because your leg was
really swollen okay so she cupped it she
needled it she did a laser on it she did
the electromagnetic field on it which
i'm gonna go buy one at cvs for a
hundred bucks so when you have an injury
you put the electro thing on there okay
and you strengthen it and the
electricity sends charges into your
muscles and into you to put blood into
that area so it heals which is what
usually happens you're supposed to give
that's why i always say to you when your
knee hurts a lot of people go my knee
hurts i'm not gonna wake up do me a
favor go put some blood in it and then
see how it feels yeah once you put blood
in that [ __ ] knee or elbow or finger
or wrist my wrist hurts once i warm it
up and i do wall push-ups and [ __ ] it's
fine yeah i could you know what i'm
saying but it's amazing you see how much
you work yourself out of doing stuff i i
had steve simone in here today and i i
was at the gym and i was just sitting in
a chair because i was finishing up a
phone call before i went in and i was at
the gym in my stuff and i was like i'm
not gonna do this i have because i have
this tonight i have to go home and do
something a little some of this
something i was like i'm not going to do
it and i just did it and it's it's
amazing how much time you can waste
watching tv
and i think i'm the way i am yeah
you know why i think i'm the way i am
because i know
that when i sit down in the afternoons
and i watch tv sometimes unless i have
ice on my knee i feel horrible even if
it's just 10 minutes with the baby yeah
i feel terrible about myself because i
know in the back of my mind there's
something else positive i could be doing
yeah there's something i could be doing
i understand people's concerns with
children watching tv i grew up on tv me
too i mean that was my babysitter who
the [ __ ] you kid now and i loved it i
loved it you know i could see mur i
don't want mercy to be involved in
television but i can see her singing
songs now from bubble guppies she says
guppy you know whatever little things
she's learning you know my daughters are
[ __ ] cut hair away from putting a
sentence together
sorry about that folks
she really is she's a conte away
you know she goes she'll say
a bubble and then she'll go
and then she'll stop the [ __ ]
sentence i don't know what the [ __ ]
she's saying sounds like a little
apocalypto i just have a conversation
with her but the more i talk to her the
smarter she's gonna be the more i talk
to i ask her questions i drill it even
if you don't ask me i don't give a [ __ ]
i ask the questions where do you want to
go what do you want to eat she don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about
maybe she does but one day she'll put
that whole sentence together like the
mermaid and [ __ ] uh
whatever and then you're gonna be in
trouble oh my god she starts saying [ __ ]
you guys isis don't kill black people
i'm gonna have problems at daycare no
she's gonna
turn off sons of anarchy it's bubblegum
it's time though oh she throws a fit
when you turn on tv let's give a shout
out to some [ __ ] sponsors we can wrap
this [ __ ] up so people can go to bed or
keep [ __ ] typing at work and i want
you wasting time listening to this [ __ ]
you could be making money
on it
i can't say enough about on it they have
helped me throughout this uh surgery
with the hemphorse protein
they've also helped me with the strong
bone they've also helped me with the
alpha brain to keep my [ __ ] head
focused in the game to help me write
joke listen man
it's it's not a mineral it's not a
[ __ ] vitamin it's a lifestyle on it
it's a very positive obsolete you're
always going to get something good when
you take care of yourself when you put
time into yourself you know you're
having problems with something get a
workout regimen going even if you're
just walking do yourself a favor go to
honor.com look what they have to offer i
get you 10 percent off on all the
vitamins and all the optimization stuff
the the the [ __ ] uh alpha brain and
which has a hundred percent money back
guarantee you don't even have to return
it uh hem force protein the new mood is
great if you need help sleeping dog the
new mood is [ __ ] good i haven't taken
a while in fact i got to call orlando it
might help
me yeah it might help me a little bit
you're right i might i might do i took
them for a while yeah and you know i
still take the
turn around 360s i had a couple packages
left yeah i take a long
to everything they do they really do
help out whether you travel whether
you're looking to work out whether
you're a fighter where you're just
getting started go to honor.com look
around see what they got to offer you
you know they got kettlebells and all
that stuff i can't help you with that
like i said i'm here for the vitamins if
you want alpha brain go to honor and
press church in the box c-h-u-r-c-h boom
get 10 percent off sent right to your
[ __ ] house if you want to send the
house every month they have a stay on it
program go down it trust me i wouldn't
[ __ ] lie to you again meundies.com
listen i have a pair of the mom right
now i got those [ __ ] uh the the
subway fair ones what are the camouflage
ones because i put those on for jiu
jitsu so i took a shower i put the other
pair on my head you need to know about
meundies.com they have the most
comfortable underwear you've ever
[ __ ] tried they fit perfectly they
don't ride up on your [ __ ] they
literally pull moisture away from your
skin i told you the story last week i
had them on for 24 hours without taking
a shower my balls smelled delicious
that's confidence right there you pay
for that you pay for that when you get
me on these do me a thi go to
meundies.com check out the pics of all
the different styles of underwear for
girls guys check out those hot looking
boy shorts if you're gay i don't [ __ ]
know men and women high quality
materials for you you know what i'm
saying right the price i'm glad you
asked it's a fraction of what you're
spending on your underwear right now do
me a favor help me out go to
meundies.com let me help you the [ __ ]
out go to meundies.com get 20 off your
first order 20 off your first order when
you go to meundies.com
joey right now and i'll tell you what
we're going gonna do we're gonna give
you free shipping in u.s and canada you
canadians you need to tighten up those
[ __ ] nut sacks we're gonna guarantee
you
guarantee you you're gonna be happy with
them especially if you go to jiu jitsu
they fit perfectly trust me once you
feel with me undies on your body you're
not going to want to [ __ ] take them
off but to get the 20 off you got to go
to meundies.com
joey is that correct that's correct all
right why are we [ __ ] around here the
best the best i talked about value at
the beginning of the show the definition
of value is a great solid product for a
little bit of [ __ ] money compared to
what's out there hit e-cigs are the best
longer-lasting better tasting guaranteed
1200 [ __ ] pups not only that the
company is [ __ ] solid they're a solid
bunch of guys megawagaba these guys are
[ __ ] solid they came out to the show
i got to meet the whole brass i know
what their [ __ ] mission is you know
to help people quit smoking to help to
be safer not to be offensive with their
[ __ ] smoke you know because it smells
like whatever anyway and they have
cigars and they're just like cigarettes
they got different flavor this cigar is
great this cigar is great you go to the
community so you'll see me smoking this
[ __ ] cigar go to helly6.com and press
what joey's church joey's church get 20
off let me tell you something that 20
bucks you get them for what 16. yeah if
it's 16 this thing lasts you
three weeks compared to anything you buy
in any of the stores go to 86.com and
get your [ __ ] money's worth whether
it's cigar whether it's a cigarette a
plane
go to me on uh
also
everybody likes free
who doesn't like free i'm here to give
you something for free oh [ __ ] okay
you ready for this i'm ready get close
to the [ __ ] speakers here
naturebox.com
why [ __ ] around two words free snacks
i'm gonna give you a chance to get free
snacks drop the [ __ ] candy bar drop
the potato chips drop all that [ __ ]
they're not good for you you know this i
know this get delicious wholesome snacks
delivered right to your [ __ ] house
you understand me i mean delicious
snacks from the black and uh the salt
and pepper lentil things to the to the
chirachi almonds uh
the sriracha
cashews to i mean the the new blueberry
whole wheat raspberries everything they
have sunflower seeds sunflowers corn
kernels that weren't really poor kernels
are [ __ ] delicious
yeah that's what they sent me delicious
listen why [ __ ] around you they don't
even have you have gluten free they got
zero artificial colors sweeteners zero
grams trans fat and no high fructose
corn syrup why [ __ ] around you're gonna
hear it from me get the cocoa almonds
get the baked uh the sweet potato fries
get the peanut butter nom noms or the
[ __ ] chocolate nom noms i'm gonna try
those oh [ __ ] it's cool because when you
sign up they're like do you like crunchy
stuff do you like chewy stuff they they
go through what you go through it guys
go there get the free box sent to your
house right now get your free trial go
to naturebox.com
joey what is it lee it's joey yeah slash
joey naturebox.com joey or go to the
joeydiaz.net stay full stay strong don't
[ __ ] around these are the best things
going to get your free thing go to
naturebox.com
joey yeah you're welcome [ __ ] and the
cool thing is it's totally free they
don't charge you for shipping
so it's it's like honestly you're gonna
need snacks you're [ __ ] stoned right
now right now you're gonna have a
sriracha [ __ ] walnut whatever [ __ ]
sriracha cashew stop [ __ ] around
right now right now go to naturebox.com
press slash join get a free [ __ ] box
shipped to the house why are we doing
this nailed it live.com these guys are
the original my man dave i love these
[ __ ] guys like lee said every time
you see him they were giving everybody
[ __ ] snacks the comedy central thing
the cameraman the mexican sweep and they
don't give a [ __ ] they want everybody to
be high the best vaper pen on the market
they also have t-shirts there they have
a bunch of stuff do me a favor after you
get your free box animation box
go to uh no nail.life.com and press what
joey diaz but honestly go there first
because you're going to want to have the
snacks by the time you get this pen who
do you think you're [ __ ] with here do
me a favor i don't know if you've seen
this chain around my neck especially
live in hudson county or the new york
city area uh
there's gold like when you go to zales
and all that [ __ ] you get ripped off
and then there's people who take care of
you you know when i went home uh this
time i bought a chain little thing from
my daughter and this last time this time
i bought a ring from my wife when i got
married to my wife all i had was 40
bucks so we got a walmart ring for 40
bucks and i always wanted to give her
some so for our fifth anniversary next
month i wanted to save up money and give
her a ring i got a ring i went there and
found the ring i can't even tell you the
price for a one carat [ __ ] ring that
he gave me he was cheaper than [ __ ] his
name is mike go to crespo's jewelers
they're in union city [ __ ] tremendous
mike will take care i spoke to him today
i called him yesterday to thank them
because i can't trust nobody out here
can't trust nobody out here you go to
zales they charge you triple for what
it's [ __ ] worth so i once said what's
the name of the jewelry plastico's
jewelry right now [ __ ] west new york
that this is not a sponsorship they're
dear friends of mine and uh they have
two locations so i told them i would
give them some love they take care of me
all the time man and that's what i'm
looking for i want them to take care of
you the same way they take care of me if
you're in the new york city hudson
county area crespo's [ __ ] jewelry and
that's it
that's the cool thing because whenever
you watch these travel shows they're
always going to these restaurants and
having these amazing adventures and
you're like if i'm going to i go to
china i'm not going to get that the
coolest part about the stuff we we have
as partners here is that you can have
exactly what we're having
it's like it's it's pretty awesome we
don't [ __ ] around here at the church man
i'm happy you guys tuned them tonight
uh i don't know how to say this i'm
sorry about [ __ ] monday things happen
you know what i'm saying things [ __ ]
happen but anyway you guys know i love
you the deck remember 10 8 october 8th
i'm at the long beach laugh factory
october 9th through the 11th i'm at the
denver
improv improv and 10 15 through the 18th
of summer i'm at the baltimore i forget
the name of the [ __ ] let me look it up
can you believe that [ __ ] the toy
factory the laugh factory you need an
edible
i'm sorry i just burped into the [ __ ]
microphone all right you are at the uh
oh let me check here
you are at the comedy factory in
baltimore only factories 16 17. let's
just start with [ __ ] the long beach
lab factory in denver right let's just
get those dates down do me a favor guys
i love you guys thank you for listening
thank you very much for the 10 million
downloads liam myself want to thank you
for being great [ __ ]
a great network we have here we got a
lot of love and you guys know when you
come to see me i love each and every one
of you from talking lair with all my
[ __ ] heart to the oscar nunez to leon
to cleo you know there's just so many
used to my main man water box and his
beautiful wife
you guys have given us so much love
constantine rain i mean there's so many
[ __ ] people laura oh my god the list
goes on and on and on joey brooklyn
thank you thank you i'm not the cleanest
guy in the world i'm not the funniest
guy in the world but i love you
[ __ ] and i appreciate you
like you wouldn't believe you guys have
changed my [ __ ] life because you've
made me that much better so i want to
thank you for what you've done to me the
last two years lee you got to tell these
[ __ ] anything no it's just it's
you're right it's and it's not
a lot of people say fans and you said
it's from the beginning
but freaking if you don't want to be a
fan i can't have your freaking token
layers like my best friend in vegas now
he he he he he torments me because he
knows i'm jewish and he always posts
these pictures of his samuels three
thousand of nearly samuels is hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious you know we've been
blessed with some great people in our
lives man
and i know you hear a lot of [ __ ] and
fake [ __ ] things if you know anything
about me i really appreciate you guys i
really appreciate what you've done for
my life and how you've kept me in check
and how you've made me a better [ __ ]
man you make me write and you make me do
good things for you guys to be healthy
because i want you to do the same
uh i became a comedian not because i'm
better than you [ __ ] guys i became a
comedian because i was a loser and i had
nothing else to do and there's nothing
else i wanted to try and this is where
we are now and i want you people to know
you could all do the same thing whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do it's not about
comedy or money just be happy and smoke
dope and eat somebody's [ __ ] and but
the most important thing to live your
life how you want to [ __ ] live it on
your terms [ __ ] i love you thank you
for watching the church every week
all right guys now that the show's over
don't forget go to naturebox.com and
sign up to get a free sampler box free
of great tasting healthy snacks that's
honestly it's free they don't even make
you pay for shipping so why not try it
out forget the vending machine and start
snacking smarter with delicious treats
like barbecue kettle kernels
i like how you said you're not having
edibles but yeah you have a bag full of
weed so i mean not stopping what's the
difference
go to naturebook.com
joey that's naturebox.com joey and
you're gonna get a free box
also go to meetundies.com
and you're gonna get 20 off of your
first order and free shipping in the
united states and canada on any of their
great men's underwear women's underwear
they have socks they have any product
you need it's better than what you're
getting now you smoke some more pot
right now
that's i can't wait thank god you have
the me undies on that's right
so go to there meundies.com joey it's 20
off of your first order and they give
you free shipping so that's even more
because you know how these companies uh
kill you with the shipping go to
onnit.com use codeword church to get 10
percent off any of their amazing
products like
new mood stream tech immune shroom tech
sport
this show is also sponsored by hit
e6.com
the proof is in the vape they have
e-cigarettes and e-cigars for you
anything you want to try they have use
code word joey's church that's joey's
church and you're going to get 20 off of
your order
and
go to nailediatlife.com for all the oil
and wax smokers out there they have the
best vapor pen on the market they're
great guys to do business with
go to nick